Okay, the answer is the paternal grandmother.
And the reason is, because only the paternal
grandmother shares the chromosome segment with the
HERC2 gene, not the maternal grandmother. And the
significance behind this is actually pretty exciting.
We know that Seamus must be homozygous recessive
and his parents, Joanna and Hayward, must
be heterozygous dominant. But he inherited a HERC2
gene containing segment of his chromosome 15
from his paternal grandmother. That means from
Susan, even though she had brown eyes, she must have been heterozygous for the
HERC2 gene, which was passed down to Hayward, which he then passed down to his
son Seamus. So even though Hayward and Susan both had brown eyes, his paternal
grandmother was responsible for giving Seamus
the allele that made his eyes blue.